Hello everyone live here in the room and on live stream around Google.
Kari Byron is no stranger to fans of her multiple reality based science oriented
television shows from discovery channel's mythbusters to Netflix's white rabbit
project to the travel channel thrill factor in many other programs.
Carrie is also no stranger to Google.
I had the privilege of interviewing her for toxic Google a couple of years ago
when she cohosted the Google science fair with youtubers Samoan yet.
And Carrie just joined stem toy companies,
smart girls as their chief creative officer as though she hasn't had done enough
amazing things.
So today we're welcoming carry back to Google to talk about her autobiographical
first book crash test girl,
which applies the scientific method to the ups downs and in betweens of life.
Please welcome Carrie to Google
[inaudible].
I like how you entered that as her first book as if like there's going to be so
many more.
I
there are because your book is awesome.
So I had a chance to learn a new word galley copy,
which is something I had to Google a,
it's a prerelease copy of the book before.
It's totally done.
I had to Google it too.
I didn't want to ask the publicist what's a galley copy cause I'd feel like I
should know that.
So,
so you didn't just write this book,
you created some amazing sketches and we're going to show some of those a little
bit and illustrations to compliment the text.
Walk me through how you created the opportunity to write the book,
not just the book itself,
but how you actually made that opportunity happen.
And the process of writing at first book,
I would like it to be something very grand,
but uh,
so I was in a bar in Iowa and I was sitting around with this random group of
people.
Um,
I mean it was,
it was Thomas Dolby,
you know,
the guy who wrote,
she blinded me with,
if you're an audio nerd,
you probably know who he is because he's invented so many amazing things.
Um,
homer Hickam who wrote rocket boys,
which became October sky,
he was there.
Um,
I had space gal,
you know,
Emily.
Okay.
Uh,
also there was a storm chaser.
Reed Timmer was there and a former astronaut and we just had this wild group of
people that had done a speaker series and we were all hanging out closer to last
call.
Then I'd like to admit,
and homer Hickam is like,
you know,
we're training all these travel stories,
like you should write a book.
It's like,
no,
I don't want to do that.
He's like,
that's what you do.
Like writing is really hard.
Every time I do a blog,
I agonize until the last minute and it's constantly being written in my head and
then it's just,
it's stressful and then I write it and I'm happy,
but that happiness is so short lived because it's just all at the end because I
got it done and it's never perfect enough.
And he's like,
no,
just write a book.
You've got all these stories,
you've got so many stories.
Write a book.
And I said No.
And he basically double dog dared me and I went,
fine,
fine.
You can let your agent call me.
So his agent called me,
said,
ah,
homer tells me that you're going to write a book.
It was like
at that time in the morning,
I'm not writing a book.
And then I just kind of let it sit and I was talking to my daughter about
something that she had going on at school,
something that she was afraid of and I was looking at her saying the words,
okay honey,
bravery.
It's,
it's not what superheroes have.
It's not having super powers.
It's being scared to death and doing it.
Anyways,
I went and I walked out the room,
I could write a book now.
So I called back the agent.
I was like,
how do you do this?
What do I do?
And he walked me through this,
you got to write a book proposal.
So I wrote a horrible book proposal that was like 90 pages long and I took it to
some publishers and I didn't get the reception that I was hoping for.
So I pulled it back and I actually hired someone to help me with the book
proposal.
It's like s like a writer that's actually good at this.
I was like,
how do I make this something that people actually want to buy?
And so she cut into pieces and brought it down to like 30 pages instead of 90,
which is insane.
And,
uh,
I went back to a bunch of publishers and got a whole bunch of different offers.
So it's really just the presentation.
I'm like,
okay,
this is actually kind of cool.
Like writing a book is hard,
but the learning process is amazing and it has all of the things that I've
always preached to my daughter,
you know,
don't be scared,
make opportunities,
you know,
learn from failure.
So the,
the first going out with the book was somewhat of a failure,
learn from it,
called an expert,
very mythbuster.
He went back out with it,
got a bunch of offers,
and then all of a sudden I went,
oh no,
I got to do it for reals.
Ah.
So I spent a lot of time stress eating and drinking wine during the day in my
living room.
Maybe I should be more of a role model about that.
But that's just my process.
Um,
I took a bunch of stories from journals.
I had a bunch of stories written on my computer already that I had written down
along the way.
I had videos from all of these years at mythbusters and you're like,
talk to all my friends.
I'm still friends with a lot of the gang.
So I'd be like,
Hey,
you remember that time?
And then I'd be like,
yes.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
I remember that.
Taking notes,
MCAT.
So I put together,
um,
a lot.
Uh,
I had never realized how collaborative of book process is as well.
You've got a designer that tells you your,
your pictures are good or bad or the wrong size.
You've got two,
three editors that keep coming back at you with new versions of the book that
take entire chapters out to say things like,
nobody wants to read about your childhood.
Okay.
That's gone.
More embarrassing stories.
Could you give us more embarrassing stories?
Oh yes.
Okay.
So,
you know,
finally after,
I think it takes about a year or so before I had the end and I'd already spent
the advance.
So I put out my version of mortified for everyone.
There's a lot of stories that are very,
um,
I,
I make myself very vulnerable.
Um,
I definitely talk about a lot of things that I don't think people expect it.
It's not a science book for kids.
It really is my personal memoir and you know,
I always like memoirs and I never liked them about people who were clean and had
it all figured out.
I like messy people who learned it along the way.
So that's my book
building on that.
Uh,
you know,
I wasn't sure what to expect cause I got this galley copy.
I knew it was a book and it was about you and that's all I knew going in.
And uh,
I was really surprised you just touched on this,
that it was so raw and personal.
It wasn't the pristine social network fantasy that represents nobody.
Yes.
It was kind of a real version of Kari Byron.
So what was it like sharing so many aspects of your private life?
Did you draw the line anywhere?
Where were,
where did you decide,
decide to draw the line?
I mean I,
I put a lot of private stuff in there and it wasn't until after I turned it into
the editors and I realized that,
Oh my God,
my dad and mom are going to read this and I told the story of losing my
virginity.
I want to puke right now but I already spent the advance.
So two eight now it's going to be a theme of this talk because pretty much go.
So you also narrated the audio,
but you can't do a book now pretty much without doing an audio book.
Was that a fun,
tedious,
painful,
all the above?
It was somewhat excruciating for a couple reasons.
One,
I'm,
I've never liked the sound of my own voice.
I don't think anybody does,
but that's a long period of time to listen to your own voice.
Also,
when I read the whole thing out loud,
I wanted to change stuff cause I had done it so silently for so long that the,
the audio book version is actually slightly different than the finish process of
the actual books.
So the more polished version is in words.
So if you want to,
I prefer you read it,
then listen to,
there are a couple of things I'm like,
that doesn't sound like me.
What am I wrote?
That way it's no change.
So I want to do a little show and tell.
Now we give editing time for,
let's see.
So there's a lot of really cool art work in the book
and uh,
want to have carry more like sketches that mostly were in my journal that I just
trace.
All right,
well there I'm not,
I can't go through all these,
but I will kind of just talk about this.
It says love is the smile that smiles back.
Can I give you a little secret?
Originally that was for something.
I took it out of a journal at originally said You die alone so you might as well
be happy with yourself.
But they didn't like that.
So
I changed it to fit the chapter insight information.
I've never told us about editors.
That's a good choice.
Now
going the other end of the spectrum,
this is um,
a,
a weapon that you could use to attack a Zombie.
I go through,
this is
part of my,
my Zombie apocalypse kit.
I do really have this in my house.
It has a roll of duct tape.
It has a machete because for some reason over Christmas,
um,
a couple of years ago to different people gave me machetes.
I don't know what that says about their two machetes.
One Christmas.
So I've got one in my Zombie apocalypse kit that,
I mean everybody has that right.
And then a bottle of unopened champagne because at the end of the world I want
to be able to save her a bottle,
drink the champagne.
And I have two weapons,
very sharp bottle for a good eye socket gouge and a machete cause machete.
So I'm a Zombie fan myself.
Now I've had many debates and red prior companies about Zombie attack.
So would you,
uh,
this is not one of the questions I wrote,
but I want to ask it now is,
uh,
where uh,
where would you rather be in a Zombie apocalypse?
Who would you rather be in a basement?
Would you rather be in a deserted island?
Would you rather be on a boat or would you rather be in your apartment?
Jamie's workshop,
Jamie's words?
That would be a good place to be.
All right.
I'm going to choose one.
Uh,
one more.
let's see.
Oh,
I like,
I like this one.
All right.
Cause I think it's a good theme for the book.
The harder I work,
the luckier I get.
And I think that there's a lot of threads in the book that,
that tie back to this concept.
So what does that mean to you?
That state?
Yeah.
Well,
I know it's,
uh,
you know,
like a Thomas Jefferson quote,
but I saw the back of a tattoo parlor
and it was just about this scrappy guy that just made his way,
uh,
even though he had some physical disabilities and I was like,
yes,
that guy successful because he worked very,
very hard.
And for me,
I've,
I've never necessarily had it easy.
I mean,
yes,
I am a white suburban girl,
so I haven't had it too hard.
But I've always worked very hard for my opportunities from getting my job at
mythbusters.
Like I worked for free and busted my ass to stay in that job.
And I've always worked very hard and it's created opportunities.
The reason I'm sitting here now is because I keep pushing myself as much as I
can to do weird and wild things.
And it's,
um,
generally beyond the scope of what I'm comfortable with.
I'm constantly making myself uncomfortable to get to the places I want to be.
Cool.
Um,
so I love the premise of the book,
uh,
that the scientific method can be applied to life,
not just science and engineering problems.
And I thought that was a really cool kind of Hook for the book.
So how do you define the scientific method,
but more importantly,
how did that concept become the unifying theme
book?
Well,
I needed a good way to tell the story that was very cohesive of a lot of strange
different pieces of my life.
And very early on in mythbusters,
we realized that the perfect narrative vehicle for busting a myth and telling a
story in the allotted amount of time that we had was to use the scientific
method.
And that was sort of the start the story arc for all of our myths.
And uh,
you know,
the scientific method is really just a tool in critical thinking.
And so you can apply that to any decision that you have make because it's all
really about creating a spearmint,
this Lauren creating an experiment and then analyzing it and finding the
conclusions that are going to help you learn.
So whether you fail or it's things turn out well,
it's all about going through that process.
So you devote an entire chapter to money among many other topics.
Um,
you weren't born with a silver spoon to carry you at all and people may not
assume that given your success,
you really hustled tomato bills,
you work multiple jobs nights as a sampler,
uh,
for liquor brands arbitraging a secondhand clothing via thrift shops.
You know,
what did you learn from those days of hustling to pay the bills?
It helps you out today.
I mean,
the hustle is hard when you're young and I,
I really did learn that there's always a way,
as long as you keep looking for it.
Like,
I really did enjoy San Francisco.
I,
I'm sure a lot of you remember used to be just this real thrifty haven and you
used to be able to go out to the rich suburbs and by,
you'd look around for a designer shoes and be like,
oh,
those are fair.
Gamo yes,
$2.
Thank you charity run by nuns.
I'm going to go to San Francisco and sell these for 20 at the thrift store on
Haight.
And I used to make a huge living like,
well huge.
I W I paid the rent with that.
But you know,
I think that I just learned that there's always a hustle somewhere and you just
have to kind of think outside the box,
which you guys do well here.
I think everybody probably has the hustle here.
I like that having the hustle.
You also touch on love and I won't get into losing virginity stories.
Um,
awkward.
Uh,
but you also chair this really touching anecdote about your husband and fellow
artists.
Paul giving you the gift of 365 love letters,
one for each day of the year,
who's had raises the bar.
Okay.
A celebrity's seemed to struggle with relationships.
What is given your relationship staying power despite celebrity and I'm sure a
lot,
and you write about imperfections along the way?
You know,
I,
I just,
uh,
I'm an accidental celebrity.
I'm not really a,
I'm not somebody who sought out this life in any way.
And I live in San Francisco,
you know,
we don't have a big celebrity culture.
And I met my husband before all of this nonsense and he's always been a big
support to me and I'm a big support to him.
And I honestly think that,
uh,
I fell in love with the person that felt like a chemical reaction rather than an
analog.
Like he didn't check the right boxes,
but he just felt right.
So for me it was more about biology than it was say.
I think Tinder and all,
that's an amazing thing for filtering,
but I think it's the real human contact that's going to keep you together.
Yeah.
And kind of human contact.
Um,
you know,
you mean you meet a lot of people in your,
in your role,
uh,
and they know you through your media persona and you write a interestingly about
sometimes feeling lonely went around lots of people and that you don't mind
being alone necessarily.
And you write about amazing experiences you've had with complete strangers.
You know,
what have you learned about friendship when so many people assume or want to be
your friend?
Well,
I mean,
I feel like you have different places that you have different people that you
need.
You might have that one friend that you bicycle with in that one friend that you
get everything you need from for a day and you may not ever see them again.
So I,
I,
when I'm traveling a lot,
I've got that,
yeah,
I'm not famous enough for somebody to be like pointing me out on the street.
I can go to a bar and still hang out with a stranger.
And sometimes I meet the most amazing people just while I'm on the road and
having one on one conversations and I never tell them what I do for a living.
I kind of skirt around it,
then I can have a friendship for a minute.
All right.
I want to do a little bit more show and tell because there's so many cool things
back here.
All right,
so this is where editing comes in.
So tell me,
but isn't it live streams?
This is the all the live stream.
They can see all the unedited,
but this is going to,
youtube is going to get the edited version.
All right.
So tell me a little bit about this interesting piece of art.
You see how that's,
so I have grown a,
a passion for black powder over the years and it's not just the explosive yeah.
Nature of it.
I always liked sort of the detritus sit left behind and I always noticed that
after we do explosions,
I would go kind of check out the mayhem that are left behind and there was a
beautiful artistic ness to the chaos.
So I,
I have,
um,
I will use black powder and paintings.
I will fence it off in some way.
I always thought round things always just looked like planets to me and I try to
control the chaos as much as possible,
but you can't replicate it twice the same way.
So I explode black powder of different grains and then I paint within it to try
to make these sort of spacey like themes and interior designers seem to like
them.
I've been like,
I either sell them at art auctions or if you know for charity or this one's
going into somebody's home I believe.
Do you have a deal of challenge that TSA if you go get on a flight right after
you've done black powder artwork,
I'll tell you what,
I have gone straight from the bomb range through Tsa several times with it just
all over me exploded ordinance and didn't get tagged at all.
But you make fun of the Tsa once on social media.
And Tori and I are completely separate parts of the,
the,
you know,
the lines and both of us got the serious pat down.
Apparently they found explosives on my phone.
I mean,
it's been years and they,
they I,
I got,
I think they're there.
I don't want to watch lists now.
So,
all right,
so you know,
you've actually talked about some of these last time and you graciously agreed
to bring,
let's see if it's,
I'll hold this up for the,
so describe,
uh,
what this little fella is and where he came to be.
So there,
there's,
there's two kinds of parenting.
There's the good parenting and then there's the creative parenting.
I'm the kind of mom that like when my kid isn't brushing her teeth,
I'll show her pictures of like meth teeth and be like,
Eh,
you want to be like this?
I'd be like,
that's what happened to you.
She hasn't figured out yet.
Yeah.
Googled.
So,
uh,
these little characters are a series of creative parenting that I touch on in
the book where my child and I,
um,
we work through her disgusting habits and all children have so many that there's
a lot of material there by creating these monsters that are supposed to be
mommies manners,
monsters.
These are lessons.
So this guy is the nail biting monster.
It's attracted to the smell of freshly chewed nail beds.
And when you fall asleep at night,
if you to do your nails,
it will come in and finish them off.
These are the booger monsters,
which they live in your nose.
And if you go up there,
pick your nose and you steal their food,
they're going to get hungry and go into the next available whole,
which might be your ear and it'll go into your brain and it will eat that.
And then you won't learn to read.
And just one note.
So this is a pretty macabre and kind of a,
I think you put this out on social media,
but um,
describe what this is all,
I just do a lot of tiny little sculptures.
I live in San Francisco and everything has to be tiny and compact there.
So I work a very,
very often in this size or as much,
much smaller.
But um,
this one was somewhere around the time of contract negotiations leave where I
was being told to be part of the machine.
So I,
I do a lot of sculptures that just are how I work out.
My feelings at night is better in a little studio.
Then say getting very angry and putting out blogs.
I,
I make them personal
also.
Yes.
By doing that,
that angry email that you send in a few seconds,
a little hard to do the angry sculpture,
you have a little more time to reflect and refine and decide.
Yeah,
yeah,
I make better decisions that way.
Then Facebook,
so you write about in your book about having an artsy punk aesthetic,
uh,
about redefining yourself as a rebel.
How important is style and is that,
how important is that for young people to think about
is really important to me.
When I was young it was,
I mean,
when I started mythbusters,
I had so many piercings that just,
it did,
it all sort of kind of fell away the older I got.
But I think that it's important to be respectful for the right places that
you're going to like,
you know,
you're,
you're definitely not going to wear your boobie shirt at grandmas,
but,
uh,
I think that,
it definitely is something when you're young,
it's a really interesting process of how you're trying to define yourself and
the people that you were around.
Cool.
Ah,
so you,
there's a couple of days,
the book that kept pretty serious and I want to touch on a couple of those
because I think it's valuable for other people going through several things.
Uh,
you're right about that.
You like the control of sobriety.
That said you write openly about alcohol both as a liquor brand ambassador and
going through what you'd call a saturated period,
you know,
what was your trigger to change your relationship with ally?
The hall?
I mean,
mostly it was having a job that I really cared about.
You can't really show up with a hangover when you work with power tools though,
you know,
it's an Australian production company.
We had a very healthy relationship with the end of the day and uh,
you know,
alcohol,
like it slowly became more interesting to me to not overdo it.
I,
um,
I have depression and so I found that in my youth I self medicated a lot with
alcohol and,
uh,
it's something that I see a lot of kids do because they don't understand.
They're depressed.
They think that they just have problems with the world that they're in.
And you know,
uh,
I,
I think a lot of kids start drinking very young and very heavily to fix that.
And so I kind of wanted to put it out there that that's what I was doing and the
mistakes that I made.
So that maybe,
maybe you figure out that you're going through hormonal depressions rather than
ending up in alcoholic because you're trying to fix something that isn't
actually a problem.
That's external.
It's internal.
I mean,
that's a perfect lead into an area that I thought was the most powerful.
And the book was where you talk openly about,
uh,
you know,
wrestling with depression for many years and uh,
it,
it is not something people would probably assume from this media persona that
inevitably follows you around.
So how did you become aware that you had something called depression?
I mean,
it really was.
When I was,
I started on mythbusters and I had my,
I had this dream job and I had a husband,
well,
he was my boyfriend at the time,
but I had this man that I was in love with.
I had a great apartment,
I had everything.
And there was nothing wrong and I couldn't assign blame to anything.
And I was like,
oh my God,
this,
this is,
this feels chemical.
This is something that I can't control.
And so that's when I started to address it in that way.
And that's how I figured out how to deal with it.
But,
uh,
the reason that I put it in the book is because I had met a woman on the road,
um,
that a young woman,
she was in college and she was saying,
I get depression and how do you make it through when you're trying to achieve
these goals,
but you're weighed down.
And,
uh,
you know,
I started to tell her I had the same thing and I could see it in her eyes that
it was almost like relief to her that this person that she saw on TV that she
thought was always happy and always had it together,
had the same thing that she had.
And she it,
it seemed to,
you know,
it touched her and she told me later she's like,
that really helped me when and hype like okay well if I can do that,
I mean I might as well put it in the book.
What have I got to lose?
I can help somebody possibly with it
and you you tried everything.
You've tried to all kinds of different strategies,
medicinal strategies,
toughing it out,
strategies,
everything in between what have and and different things will work for different
people.
What has helped you manage depression even though it's probably always going to
be with you for the rest
scientific method?
I did a lot of experimenting and I mean for me personally being somebody who
likes the dark rd side,
I medicating didn't work for me.
I found the side effects horrendous.
I found it very difficult and I tried and tried in different ways and I honestly
find out I go completely sober.
I I exercise like a,
like a crazy person for the endorphins.
I eat super duper healthy and I don't,
I know that it's going to pass,
which is now I know what it is.
I know it's going to go away.
It's made it a lot easier.
I also put myself in social situations with other people.
I find that it actually really helps to not lock myself away and hide it.
Well thanks for sharing that so openly in the book cause there's other people
that will probably never would have assumed that,
you know,
will make a difference.
So just a couple more questions before I open it up to the Dory and the folks in
the room.
Um,
so you actually read the book,
a lot of people that interview me or Oh,
I just asked mythbuster questions the whole time.
No,
I actually read the book.
I read the book on a,
on a,
on a flight to Nashville actually.
And a,
it is a perfect four hour round trip length flight book.
Oh,
fantastic.
Airport book stores.
Exactly.
So,
um,
mythbusters was an amazing contribution to reality television and it was really
sad on the show.
Inevitably came to an end.
You dedicate an entire chapter to setbacks,
including how mythbusters ended.
What have you learned from those setbacks that help you going forward?
I mean,
I,
I thought that the world was ending for a minute when I left mythbusters,
cause that had been my first,
you know,
it was just such a huge job.
It was,
it was over a decade long and it was everything I knew and it was everything
that I'd put in all my passion and heart into for so long that I was suddenly
completely unqualified to do anything else because nobody needs you to drive a
forklift and you know,
blow things up in regular jobs.
I was terrified.
I went to the mall,
I bought a pair of theory slacks that was about to get my linkedin already.
I'm just saying,
okay,
I don't know if this is God.
There's just no boxes for what I do.
I have no idea.
So,
you know,
being able to kind of gather myself from that and like,
okay,
what do I like to do?
What do I want to do?
Okay,
I like this TV thing.
Maybe I can do this TV thing.
I'm going to keep going.
So I actually just started going out and pitching shows on my own and letting
people know that I'm still here and I'm ready to work on other things.
And other shows started showing up.
They're like,
oh,
mythbusters is over.
Come over here.
Yeah.
Travel channels.
Like we would love you to come,
come do science on roller coasters.
And it was,
it was a good lesson that life continues beyond even when the wonderful things
in.
So,
uh,
that's why I've,
I've continued on with TV and I'm moving into a new fun fields myself now.
Yeah.
So it's a perfect lead into my last question cause it's a,
your next gig.
Um,
you've recently joined a cool startup.
Smart girls is there?
Yes.
Got To do show and tell.
This is their last show and tell.
Okay.
So you,
um,
I'm looking forward to understanding more about the cool startup smart girls
that you recently joined as their chief creative officer,
uh,
that's creating self-balancing programmable robots targeting girls,
with action dolls.
What will your role be and how did you get connected this opportunity?
And you should definitely show this.
It's really cool.
Ck,
show it on the floor.
Let's see.
I think probably here,
right in the middle.
Guys over,
not invent this.
I,
uh,
so it's like a little segue.
I don't want her to drop off.
Hold on.
Thank you.
She's trying to learn to self balance.
So,
uh,
almost,
yeah.
Well she jumps off the edge.
It'll be more like me.
Well that'll be a,
that will be a mythbusters moment.
So there you go.
Got Her little segway.
She does that to self balance.
So I,
I
when,
um,
I thought to myself,
what do I want to do besides TV?
Because I like TV,
but I am,
it started,
you know,
it's,
it's feast or famine.
It's a little like,
uh,
sooner or later I want to do something new and I always wanted to do toys and
that's next on my bucket list is I want to work in toys.
So I just started getting on the Google and researching places that did it and
how they did it and what they did.
And I,
I talk to everybody I knew,
um,
about connections.
And,
um,
just a friend had talked to a guy who was involved in this company.
I cold called him and asked him out to coffee to pick his brain.
And by the end he's like,
wow,
you might be,
this is kind of your brand.
I mean this is a stem for girls brands.
So this is a doll on his self balancing robot that is completely codeable and it
teaches block coding to girls using their tablet or their phone so that the DOL
can move through challenges.
It can dance music comes out of it,
but it speaks to the way girls play,
which is a,
they do a lot more storytelling.
And um,
I feel like at one point the whole revolution was okay,
we got to teach girls stem.
So don't make anything pink because that's,
that's too girly and stem doesn't have to be girly.
And I feel like now that the revolution against the revolution is,
or the girls that like pink,
let's also teach them coding and computer science.
Let's make toys for everyone.
And this,
this is supposed to reach girls at the age that they stopped being interested in
coding and computer science because all the toy start getting very masculine.
They're robots in their cars and they're things that destroy.
Whereas my daughter who's in love with Minecraft and loves coding is now one of
only two girls in her entire afterschool program because every year they dropped
off,
they dropped off,
they dropped off because she likes to code in ways that create stories and she
makes these big castles that all have a reason for everything.
And then the boys in the class go in and blow it up.
So it's,
they're both really good.
It's just,
I think that sometimes we need to make it easier for girls to continue on in
this field.
So,
um,
this is just the launch toy.
This is the one that it was seen on shark tank and that's where they got their
start.
Oh,
cool.
Um,
and uh,
they want out of like 40,000 companies and they've got such a great hustle going
on that I met the founder and I was just like,
yeah,
I would like to join with you guys.
I'm going to help them in their next round of seed funding so that we can
actually start making more.
And then I've got a bunch of new coding toys that are
probably be coming out by Christmas.
Awesome.
That is so cool.
So,
um,
we're now going to shift to audience and Dory questions.
But before I do,
I have two copies of the book.
I learned that as I mentioned for this,
the Galley copy,
the one that I actually read with all the galley copy you,
I didn't know what it meant so I googled it.
So Galley copy is a,
a,
a prerelease copy of the book.
Not entirely finished there.
I someday we'll read the released coffee to see what the differences are,
how significance of the diff,
yeah,
they're not significant,
but to me they were,
they were important changes to me.
They're very small.
So the uh,
the book is fantastic.
Strongly recommend you pop out your smartphone right now in order up a copy.
And I see that our copies already in the audience just came out and uh,
it's just a really good reason.
It's very unexpected.
So with that,
um,
uh,
we will get a,
my assistant who's an engineer with our team to get the microphone.
All right.
Uh,
thanks for coming in the book.
I haven't quite finished yet,
but it's great.
It reads like it's so easy and interesting.
I really appreciated.
Uh,
and you touched on it a little bit already that you were very honest about
dealing with depression and how it was hard on Paul.
Also,
I'm wondering if you have any advice for people who find themselves in Paul's
place who want to help but don't know how to do.
So
it's really tough when you're married to somebody who does have depression.
And I think that in any family it's very difficult because you want,
you take it very personally,
like when that person is sad or angry,
it's always gonna feel like it's at you.
I think that the most important thing is to just remember it's not you and you
also have to just take care of yourself.
You know,
the,
the partner of someone who's depressed has to really understand that it's,
it's not something that they caused and,
um,
just be as understanding as possible.
But I think it's also the depressed person has to as well be very understanding
of that.
That that situation is something that is going to happen and that you have to
take extra care of each other.
Great question.
Thank you.
All right,
next take another one from the room.
Yeah.
So sort of a two part question.
Um,
we become who we are from our experiences.
So would you say that everything you've gone through in your life has been
necessary or would present day you go back in time and try to change something
that you did in the past?
That was it.
Something somebody asked me and I put some of it in the book,
uh,
Present Day me,
we'd go back and invest in Google.
I would have stocks in all of that.
That would be amazing.
But,
uh,
yeah,
I mean it definitely took a lot of tripping and falling and I don't think that I
would be here or be as happy I am with my life now if I hadn't had all of these
scary,
awful experiences are wonderful experiences.
So,
um,
I,
you know,
I wouldn't say I don't regret anything.
I just say I've definitely learned a lot.
So from the,
from the dories somewhere out on the live stream.
So what's this,
you probably get this question quite a bit.
What's the myth you most want to have revisited because you think it has to be
true but was busted on the show?
That has to be just to be true.
It was busted on the show,
but it just didn't feel like it should have been busted.
Uh,
I don't know.
I kind of agreed with most of our results except for fireworks,
man.
I was really,
I,
uh,
fireworks man where we,
we launched a guy with fireworks and I feel like the producers wanted it to not
be real.
So,
um,
they came up with a different conclusion that I came up with,
but in the end it was the group ruled against me.
So I,
you know,
I wouldn't want to actually retest that one cause it was kind of ridiculous.
In fact,
I have most of them I'm pretty satisfied with how they came out in the end.
Yeah.
I think you made a big difference around the uh,
the cell phone at the gas station.
Yeah.
I love that myth.
I thought that had a very positive impact on gas stations that used to put a
sticker,
no cell phone near the gas even though it's totally okay.
I would like people to stop firing bullets into the air when they're celebrating
because we know that they come to like that was another one that I thought was
very good that we actually had some statistical research happening from the
show.
Also,
the one that I really,
really like people to believe is the airport lines.
When you are boarding a plane where it doesn't matter what the zones you are,
if everybody just boards and does it efficiently,
the,
the most efficient people will generally get to the front of the line and
they'll do everything quickly.
And then the slacker people,
which somehow always end up in first class just like,
oh,
I ain't let me put my dog here.
And they're always in the front.
And I think it'd be so much faster if we just let nature take its course
or,
or you know,
we feel very strongly a fly a lot.
Every time you fly you should have like you should be timed and then your next
flight is adjusted based on how you performed the last time.
And then that will sort it all out and all that time.
And the people that don't mind,
I don't mind taking a long time.
There'll be at the end and they don't care.
Yeah.
So we've got other from the,
uh,
from the audience.
Here we go.
Right.
Hi.
So I,
Oh man,
I haven't read the book yet,
but it seems you've done a lot of traveling in your time.
And I was wondering what the biggest piece of advice you have for someone who
will be spending some time in an unfamiliar place?
Hmm.
Um,
it depends on con in different countries.
if you're in Egypt,
you didn't drop anything no matter how many people say,
hey,
you dropped something,
don't stop and turn around.
You didn't drop anything.
I would say it would be my best piece of advice,
but I think sometimes you got to not look at the travel blogs and just,
just let it go and explore because I think that's the most interesting part of
traveling is just stumbling things.
Like it's great to kind of have a,
an idea of where you're going.
But I generally like,
uh,
you know,
even in the United States,
like we do a lot of filming in places like Philadelphia for example.
I,
I knew that I had six hours before I had to be anywhere.
So I looked for the best vegan cheese steak I could find and it was miles away.
I'm like,
okay,
I'm going to walk there no matter what neighborhood I have to walk through.
And along the way I found so many cool things like art galleries and Weirdo
people and just like oddities shops and you know the motor museum was on the
way,
which is the medical oddities museums.
So I found so much craziness along the way just to get to the vegan cheese steak
and it was the journey,
not the reward.
It was delicious by the way,
but I had this whole entire adventure because instead of like,
okay,
I can sit in this hotel room for six hours,
I made some sort of just arbitrary destination and just let my feet take me into
the weird,
we'll take one more from the door and one more from the audience.
So I'm sure you get asked this a lot to the,
you had a chance to do mythbusters again.
What'd you or is that kind of part of your life?
Kind of had a wonderful book ends and you know that,
that's that,
I don't know,
cause mythbusters campy mythbusters again,
because I've learned a bunch from mythbusters and the whole amazing thing of the
journey is,
is that I had no idea what I was doing at all from the beginning.
Like everybody thought mythbusters was a science showed it wasn't a science
show.
None of us have a science background.
We all were just experiencing it together and learning together.
And I almost feel like a,
at this point,
I might be,
I don't know if I would have the same giant reactions to things because I kind
of know when stuff's going to blow up now.
So I'm not sure if I could do it again.
Cool.
So who wants to be our last
question?
Are down here.
No pressure.
You're the last question.
The dummy.
I fixate on mythbusters,
but um,
it's okay.
That was like,
that's the whole reason I'm here.
Jimmy and Adam have been pretty open,
but the sort of chemistry or lack thereof,
um,
at Google we have,
we talk a lot about cultural fit when we talk about a candidate.
Um,
but it sort of seems that,
you know,
their lack of chemistry has actually produced something really great.
That lesson,
you know,
for as long as it did.
Do you think is that you're more important for a successful project to have good
team chemistry or how that clash of personalities that the two I guess host had?
Well,
you can have a clash of personality,
but you still have to have a respect for each other and what you bring to the
table.
When that's gone,
it's over.
Like I,
I,
my team with Tory and grant and I,
we had amazing chemistry and so the three of us had the same,
you know,
a fun mythbuster.
He results then,
you know,
Jamie and Adam that had the clash.
But I think that the,
the common thread is that we all respected each other's skill set and what we
brought to the table and appreciated the diversity because I really do think
that diversity is the best way to solve any problem.
Cool.
And,
uh,
you know,
we still all hang out.
I still tortured story all the time.
We still prank each other a lot.
That's kind of my dream is to have a prank show.
What's your favorite,
uh,
praying if you could choose this one.
You talk about some of this in the book.
The pranks.
I mean on mythbusters we did a lot of different pranks,
but a Tory and I at one point trying to create a prank show.
It didn't get bought,
but uh,
we,
we actually perpetrated an amazing prank on some unknowing people that thought
they were on a reality show.
Uh,
we,
uh,
we brought them into watch the price per the process of cryogenics and um,
told them that it was all real and then had the cryogenically frozen people turn
into zombies and attack them
and it was hard and I am dying to put it onto the youtube at some points
secretly maybe somebody elite.
Okay,
cool.
That was the funniest I ever,
I ever perpetrated myself on a grand scheme.
But other than that,
Tory's made me vomit a lot by drinking things that I thought were bodily fluids
that were actually just like he switched it with some special effects.
Like all of a sudden he's drinking an entire beaker of old saliva and I'm
throwing up on the floor,
but it turns out it was just tea and he's a jerk.
Well,
with that
appropriate that we kind of end with a Tory story.
So,
okay.
What'd you got?
So,
um,
I want to thank you for coming back to Google a second time.
Trekking up from the or down from the city and uh,
everyone crashed us girls.
Fantastic book.
You're going to learn something from it.
It's very personal.
It's emotional.
It's not what you'd expect and highly recommended.
And I actually read the book.
Um,
so hopefully your other,
your other book tour interviews,
you get a mix of people who've read the book.
Um,
so I want to thank you again for coming back to Google.
It's been a pleasure.
Thanks for inviting me.
[inaudible].